[Music]
good morning wife
my husband asked me this is great look
out your window why I'm taking you away
for the weekend I just can't believe
this is my life then I get to live with
you
that meant nothing to me before you Anna
Gray's office we wanted to welcome the
new fiction editor
I bought it for us I should have asked
you first
Christian this is Jim Matteo the
architect this location is perfect I'm
going to build you a fabulous house
please stop speaking of my husband as if
I weren't here Anna you may call me mrs.
gray I'll pick you up a fire I may not
be done by then
we're being followed
how the hell are you Anna
Jack what do you want
so you want to play yes sir
I made a vow so once you face away
forsaking all others did you sleep with
her to comfort you in times of need and
to keep you safe first long as we both
shall live
[Music]
[Applause]
you